from hospitality to manufacturing
coronaviruses paralyzed british business
as demand drops and workers stay at home
we are starting a great national effort
to protect jobs unveiled by the
Chancellor the government's job
retention scheme subsidizes the wages of
staff allowing employers to keep them on
their books when they're not in work but
to be eligible they need to be on the
company's payroll On February the 28th
dundee based software engineer called
edith while started a new job three days
after that deadline that meant he wasn't
covered and so his new employer made him
redundant i've actually been working
continuously for over 25 years it just
so happened that this this great option
he came up for me when it did in january
and they you know i changed jobs just at
the wrong moment in time the government
scheme pays 80% of an employee's wage up
to a maximum of 2,500 pounds a month but
potentially thousands of workers who
started jobs after February the 28th get
nothing Sky News has spoken to dozens of
people who say they feel abandoned by
the government and let down by an
apparent hole in the coronavirus Support
Scheme Treasury guidance does state that
employers can rehire staff and still be
eligible for the wage subsidy but that
doesn't apply if the worker has left
voluntarily
the Treasury uses the cutoff date so
claims can be referenced to pay data
labour says it's raised the issue with
the Chancellor and the GMB Union has
called for the government to look again
but it's also causing problems for small
businesses heather Backstrom hasn't been
able to get the subsidy for one new
starter for as long as we can we're
going to pay them but unfortunately we
don't know when we're going to actually
be able to reopen at the moment so it's
quite scary for our business it's just
very confused they're confusing these
guidelines over the day of the 20th of
February I just don't understand where
they've got that day from a Treasury
spokesperson said the scheme has already
protected thousands of jobs and those
who aren't
jabal can apply for enhanced benefits
and tax deferrals and get help with
housing costs but workers who are
missing out say they've been left out in
the cold when they most needed help
Rob Powell Sky News in Westminster